>> DELTA AIRLINES IS LEARNING
THE HARD WAY THAT VIRTUE
SIGNALING CAN HAVE CONSEQUENCES.
FOLLOWING THE PARKLAND SHOOTING
DELTA ABOLISHED NRA DISCOUNT
THAT ONLY BEEN USE ON 13 AIR
TICKETS.
IN RESPONSE, GEORGIA'S
LEGISLATURE KILLED A $40 MILLION
TAX BREAK FOR THE COMPANY TO
ENJOY.
GEORGIA LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
CASEY CAGLE IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR AND HELPED LEAD THE
CHARGE TO SPLIT THE TAX BREAK.
HE JOIN US TONIGHT.
YOU SAID YOU'RE SICK OF
CONSERVATIVES GETTING KICKED
AROUND BY COMPANIES.
>> WELL, MARK, IT'S GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU TONIGHT.
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THIS WAS IN THE CONTEXT OF A
MUCH LARGER TAX CUT THAT GEORGIA
CITIZENS WERE GOING TO RECEIVE.
BOTH INDIVIDUALS.
BUT COMPANIES AND CORPORATIONS
OF OUR STATE.
DELTA WAS PART OF THAT.
BECAUSE THEY CHOSE TO TARGET AND
BE A PART OF THE BOYCOTT, THAT
REALLY TARGETED NRA AND
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS ACROSS OUR
STATE, THAT PARTICULAR TAX CUT
THAT SPECIFIC TO THEM WHICH WAS
AN EXEMPTION ON THE JET FUEL,
WAS REMOVED FROM THE
LEGISLATURE.
>> NOW, I TAKE IT THEY SAW
COUPLE OF TWEETS OR WHATEVER IT
WAS, WHO SAID YOU NEED TO
DISASSOCIATE YOURSELF FROM THE
NRA.
IN A SENSE, SOMETHING REALLY
UNPLEASANT GOING ON HERE.
THESE ARE LAW-ABIDING SENS.
THE LEFT TRYING TO SETTLING THEM
WITH THE BLAME.
AMERICANS SEEM TO BE GOING ON
WITH IT.
>> I DON'T THINK CONSERVATIVES
ARE TO BLAME.
IF IT'S NOT THE SECOND AMENDMENT
TODAY IT MIGHT BE THE FIRST
AMENDMENT TOMORROW.
WE HAVE TO STAND UP AND FIGHT
AND PUSH BACK AND DO IT IN A
RESPECT I
RESPECT -- RESPECTFUL WAY.
DELTA IS AN ECONOMIC ASSET.
WE SEE TIME AND TIME AGAIN THAT
COMPANIES ARE WANTING TO WEIGH
INTO THE SOCIAL DISCUSSION AND
LISTEN, I'VE BEEN A SMALL
BUSINESSMAN BOTH SMALL AND
LARGE.
FOR 32 YEARS.
I ALWAYS RECOGNIZE LIKE WARREN
BUFFETT, I DIDN'T LET MY
POLITICAL VIEWS GET IN THE WAY
OF MY SHARE HOLDS.
I THINK IT'S BEST WHEN COMPANIES
GET BACK TO FOCUSING ON MAKING
MONEY.
SELLING SEATS.
LET'S NOT FORGET, WITH THE NRA
IN PARTICULAR, DELTA NEGOTIATED
A DEAL IN SELLING SEATS.
NO DIFFERENT THAN HOTELS.
YOU GIVE A DISCOUNT FOR THAT.
THIS WAS VERY TARGETED.
OBVIOUSLY IT WAS NOT SOMETHING
THAT I APPRECIATED.
I EXPRESSED THAT CLEARLY.
>> HAVE YOU HEARD FROM DELTA?
>> I HAVE.